[Music]
you need to take a nap but don't feel
like going home well I'll put you to
sleep at nap Valley the happiest place
on earth
I'm performing a heart surgery in 20
minutes and I need to be well-rested
sounds like you need a nap
[Music]
sweet dreams
[Music]
it's a siesta fiesta have you heard the
news have you found the clues you can
lose your blues you can take this new
it's an app brat we've got my bed four
pillows a fully stocked pajama bar need
more milk to sleep we've got the warmest
milking down and unlike other nap stores
we use blankets not towels towels are
not blankets
[Music]
hey can I get a private room for me and
my friend no that's okay let's go find
it cool [ __ ] we have no private rooms
that's where people do bad stuff like
sex and drugs instead I'll be earn a
chaperon singing lullabies and spinning
the sheet wheel 50a are you asleep yet
so stop by our one convenient location
in the locker room level for clothes gym
and chino we've got an app with your
name on it
hi that's an app
[Applause]